let's go ahead and get started
um
we have a sign-in sheet here
if you put in your name and email would
be appreciated
and I have a few
pink slips for people will be testifying
um we'll squeeze you in when we can
between this and the second uh testimony
starting at 10 o'clock
unless uh where this will first one runs
long and that's okay too then we'll take
you afterwards
but first I'd like to welcome our uh
yes please come and introduce yourself
and make sure you have the red light on
good morning good
this is awkward because I want to face
everybody but good morning gentlemen my
name is Megan Dom I'm with the American
Beverage Association we represent the
beverage industry refreshment beverages
so you know our biggest members are Coke
Pepsi Keurig Dr Pepper Red Bull Niagara
etc etc but
just like to start by saying you know as
you know recycling programs in our
country they differ from state to state
municipality by municipality city by
City
we have a recycling national average
right now that has stagnated in the low
30 percents which there's clearly room
for improvement there
so what we know is that we're losing
valuable materials that should be used
again and again to landfills to
waterways to Nature
we don't have incentives or programs
that hold consumer brands or producers
responsible for the packaging choices
they make when delivering products to
Consumers
and recycling in most places in our
country is underperforming due to
inefficient systems or placing onus on
local governments to fix it
there's understandably great amounting
pressure from environmental groups and
lawmakers to reduce waste and many of
the largest consumer brand companies
have made ambitious environmental
commitments including robust recycled
content and recyclability and reuse
goals including our companies
voluntary action alone is not going to
achieve the scale needed to meet these
targets or retrieve critical system
change we need good policy and we need
good policy that's built upon four key
principles they're simple I'll get to
the specifics of what epr for packaging
and printed paper entails in a moment
but I just wanted to talk kind of writ
large about all policy for recycling for
Consumer Packaging
and those four pillars are one strong
environmental outcomes none of us would
be here if we didn't need to be here if
we didn't have recycling in the low 30
in our country we want to have less
material in nature packaging
strategically considered at the point of
design higher recycling rates a circular
economy two consumer convenience all
consumers should be able to recycling
something just as easily as they can
throw something away
Three Financial efficiency money in the
system stays in the system too often
money for recycling is reallocated I
think we can all agree that pensions and
roads are really important but when
we're talking about money that's been
allocated for recycling we think it
should stay there
a non-profit running the system is
really important
and there is a really important role for
government which is to set the scope of
a system and provide oversight but then
letting the private sector fund and
operate the system to meet specific
targets
the fourth is access to material in
order to create circularity and put
these valuable materials back into their
next best use and I'm talking about
materials like aluminum strong durable
Plastics like pet HDPE and polypropylene
as well as glass and paper
we need producer spill to access those
materials and at market prices so no
smoke screens here producers will pay
for the materials at the back end but
they need to be able to access them
and buy them
but we're here to talk about extended
produce responsibility and for packaging
and printed paper
an epr is run successfully in countries
around the world so if you want to
implement epr that's what I'm here to
talk about epr is simple how it works in
practice can be really nuanced
but what epr is writ large epr is a
policy that shifts responsibility for
what happens to Consumer packaging and
printed paper at the end of its life
from local governments and consequently
taxpayers who pay for it to the
producers who put packaging and printed
paper on the marketplace
and it sets targets so that producers
are funding and operating the system to
achieve efficiency but also strong
environmental outcomes
recycling today is mostly a linear
system where producers make and sell
products to Consumers who then use and
dispose of them
municipalities are primarily responsible
for collecting that stuff
and based on many different factors
including a lack of robust education a
lack of consumer access to recycling
system inefficiencies lack of
investments in collection and separation
and processing technology and even
non-existent systems too many materials
are not getting recycled and no one's
held responsible
under well-designed epr which is really
critical this word well designed because
there's all different epr but under
well-designed epr the producer
responsibility organization which is
made up of the consumer brand so you
have your Cokes your Clorox your L'Oreal
everybody all these companies that are
putting packaging on the market whether
it's recyclable or not all of them are
mandated to join a producer
responsibility organization
which is a privately run
non-profit organization
and these companies are then responsible
for operating and funding the system
from education to collection to
processing so that they can look at the
system from thirty thousand feet and
optimize the entire system from the
front to the back end
The Producers importantly are advised by
the waste industry and the recycling
Community especially the private haulers
who have a very vested interest in this
and we want to make sure that their
concerns are addressed because this is
how they make money
as well as advised by environmental
organizations material groups local
governments and other vested
stakeholders
and please interrupt me at any moment if
you want to ask questions okay
fees to run the system so you have this
entire look at the entire system you
determine how much it's going to cost
through what's called A needs assessment
so you take for example the state of New
Hampshire and you do A needs assessment
of New Hampshire and say these are the
needs of the system this is how much
it's going to cost so you know that up
front and then the fees to run that
system are assessed by different
material types so not all materials pay
the same depending on their how they
operate in the system the net cost to
recycle and then they are further what's
called equal modulated to incentivize
environmental factors like recyclability
recycle content Etc so you're paying
less if you have packaging that that
does well in the environment that is
recyclable that includes recycled
content and you're paying more if it
does not and like I said this is all
packaging and printed paper it's not
just what's recyclable it's everything
and then the producer we're gonna yes
notes it's a very nerdy term
[Laughter]
so Eco modulation is basically the idea
that you have this pot of money that you
need
you need to pay for work you need to pay
for the system and so what you do is you
allocate it based on different materials
so aluminum might pay certain fee pet
which is the plastic water bottles
um HTTP your milk jugs might pay
differently but then it's further Eco
modulated and what that means is that if
I have um recycled content in my in my
cans the average aluminum can as a 73
recycled content that's really high so
if I'm in aluminum beverage can I'm
going to pay a lot less and maybe in
some some countries like France I'm not
going to pay anything because my that
can is so recyclable that we've done our
part right so the net cost is is more
valuable at the back end and so that's
what equal modulation means
and to follow up on what just said if I
may
um
have you noticed that this is now
extended producer responsibility is very
new to these Shores but it's been
practiced in Europe and other places
around the world
has equal modulation had an effect upon
the producers how they packaged their
materials
actually the idea correct the idea is
that you know if I'm a producer and I'm
making for example a Twix and I'm not
calling on anybody but I'm thinking when
I I visited Japan that Twix for example
in our the candy bar in our country is
packaged in a multi-layer plastic
aluminum but in Japan it's packaged in
paper and so if the difference between
those material types in the U.S I'm
going to pay a lot more for that
multi-material because it's not
recyclable every time that's going in
the trash but in Japan it's made of
paper which is recyclable so I would be
paying less so yes there is a built-in
incentive and that's the that's the
entire idea is to incentivize producers
to think about packaging when they're
okay
um voila
so like I said so Investments we made
throughout the system all the way from
consumer education to access and by
access they mean that every consumer
will have a bin at their homes whether
single family or multi-family
um to collection by the haulers to
processing to commodity markets to end
markets back to producers and this
results in producers having greater
access to more recycled materials and
that increased supply of recycled
materials will of course allow producers
to use more recycled content in their
packaging which reduces the use of
Virgin materials like plastic
and while this system is operated as I
said by the private sector government
provides oversight ensures transparency
and accountability in the system and
government ultim government ultimately
approves the Pro's plan and targets but
the producer organization is ultimately
given the flexibility to meet those
targets
four states in the country have passed
epr for printed paper and packaging and
many seats have passed epr for other
things like sharps or carpets or paint
mattresses and other things but for
packaging a printed paper there have
been four
and those are main Oregon Colorado and
California
but even with just the four laws that
have passed it's abundantly clear that
there are very different ways to write
these laws and consequently we will see
wildly different outcomes for example
the law in Maine has no system change
built into it and in my opinion will not
achieve any strong environmental
outcomes because it's not part of the
law
and most of the bill proposals we saw in
2023 none of which passed saw various
groups attend to use epr as a cover for
things that aren't really epr or really
outside of the scope and I think it's
really important in this moment that we
keep epr pure about epr which is about
residential consumer Recycling and
consumer package Goods
it's not a Panacea for everything in the
Environmental Landscape and it and it
shouldn't be but when it's done well it
works but of course the devil is in the
details and I'm happy to answer any and
all specific questions you have about
epr but I just wanted to lay the lay the
land
um could you speak a little bit more
about your
opinion and the main uh
epr legislation I know it's a long
process it's in there only the very
beginning of it maybe you could speak to
that as well about absolutely where they
are and where their timeline is on that
yeah so um I did improve my cheat sheet
on that but the date the law passed was
July 2021 the issues that I have that we
have I guess I have Within Me Bill is
first it doesn't include printed paper
um I don't know about you but my
recycling bin if I think about my
recycling bin at home it's mostly
printed paper right it's your it's your
mail it's your newspapers it's all that
stuff and so if you have a system that
is focusing on residential recycling and
the idea being that we're going to pay
for the whole thing then printed paper
should surely be part of that and the
argument is that well the paper industry
thinks that their recycling rates are
high enough that they shouldn't have to
pay in but the paper recycling rate in
our country hovers in like the 60s 66
which is
a lot higher than a lot of materials
certainly but that still means that a
third of paper is not being recycled
which arguably lends for work to be done
and so I think that was a real flaw in
the system because the way that happens
if you exclude printed paper either the
rest of the producers are covering the
costs of the printed paper for them or
you still have taxpayers praying the
printed paper portion of recycling and
that goes against the entire philosophy
of epr which is to shift the cost away
from taxpayers so they're not paying for
it
um and then the other piece that we that
I have an issue with is that um the epr
law set in Maine is more of what we call
like an ATM model so the producers will
pay for the system and that's it they'll
write the check and they will have no
say about kind of where the money goes
or how the operation the operation of
the system works and so the
inefficiencies built into that system
will stay it pretty much preserves the
status quo of that main system as it
exists and the whole purpose of epr is
that the system isn't working as well as
it could and we need to make certain
changes to it and that's not built into
um
it sounds to me that
you think the most effective epr laws
are comprehensive in my original
thinking and putting this bill and
something that was brought up in the
committee
um and the ENA committee I believe was
the idea of taking it in smaller bytes
go after say paint maybe perhaps or we
already have epr for mercury in the
state
um but you're seeing a comprehensive
bill is actually be would be more
favorable to the industry is what I hear
you're saying is that correct for
packaging and printed paper so if you
were going to have an epr law for paint
or mattresses or sharps in my view those
things are separate so and absolutely
you should do those things I think that
they're very successful I'm not an
expert on on the mattress or or paying
epr laws but I think that they they work
very well they're very different though
I mean you buy a mattress how often you
buy consumer packaging every day so they
they're they're quite different so if
you're going to implement a law for
Consumer packaging and paper
then then that's what I'm here to speak
yeah thank you for taking my question so
can you explain to me how how this would
affect a mattress what is it the
packaging when you get it from the store
or how they dispose of it my
understanding and I could be wrong to
anybody watching this like not an expert
in mattresses but my understanding is
and if anybody else in the room knows
better um when you buy your mattress you
are kind of paying a advanced fee on it
for what happens to an end of life so if
it's all baked into it so if I'm buying
a mattress that has that cloth baked
into it so that at the end of it when
1 800 mattress comes in picks my old
mattress up when they deliver the new
one that is already kind of like been
peeved where to deal with the end of
life of it I do I believe that old
mattresses are kind of ripped apart and
made into new mattresses I don't really
like to think about that um but I think
that is
that is part of it but again not an
expert on mattress CPR but if somebody
I'm very naive about this
I live in co-wash County just down the
road from my house as a recycling center
and so we like if I get rid of a
mattress I just bring it there and throw
it in the auger and they
grind it up I I you know same thing with
every day when I'm in there I see bales
of aluminum bales of plastic cardboard
so everything's
done right there uh
that's surprising to me 30 is a very low
number that I I didn't realize it was
that low
yeah I mean I so it sounds to me like
you have a drop off like you put your
well you pay like you pay like
Electronics you pay a certain amount if
you have tires you pay a certain three
dollars a tire
a lot you know things like that so that
three dollars probably ensures that the
tire is going to the place where it
needs to go to get
remade into whatever happens to the tire
for the consumer packaging I think that
was what I used to do I grew up in New
Jersey that was what I did as well when
I was a kid we used to go we'd load up
the car we'd go down they had the
different Bays for the aluminum Bay the
clear glass Bay the brown glass Bay and
that is honestly a really great system
because that is you are automatically
separating that stuff but if you think
about the way we've transitioned in our
country not in your community but in
most of communities to single stream
recycling which means that at my house
right now I dump all of my stuff into
one bin and it all gets mixed together
and then the truck comes and it squishes
it and it squishes it and so by the time
it gets to the murf or the material
recovery facility which is where those
trucks go the trucks go not where you go
because that stuff is beautiful and
clean it doesn't need to go to a Murph
the only job of a Murph is to take
single stream and separate it back out
into the beautiful clean bales that that
you're talking about in your community
that's all the network does but what
happens is that stuff is so contaminated
because if you think about
some consumers aren't thinking as well
and maybe they're putting their hoses or
their hangers or their Christmas lights
in there because they can't they can get
away with that in a closed bin versus in
a drop-off you can't and the wetness of
consumer food and peanut butter and all
that stuff is
so yeah contamination is a big part of
the issue in our country and education
frankly
um we need to do a much better educating
consumers about what's put in and
whatnot
I I don't want to compare this to a tax
but I would say
the way it's happening in in Berlin it's
more like a user fee which I I would
think is is very fair but it like the
mattress thing you explained
when it's
they already charged you before you you
buy it I think that it would be
not a not a tax but it would affect the
lower income people more than anybody
and that that's where I don't absolutely
yes for Consumer packaging and printing
paper epr
um we do not support what's called like
a consumer fee a consumer site it's
called the CRF a consumer recycling fee
we do not support that we don't think
that the cost should then be borne down
to Consumers
um that epr should be the cost should be
born by the producers and not consumers
or taxpayers
okay
thank you
thank you um one more finally
um
I'm hearing a lot of good stuff here
if we are really concerned
as a committee as our charge says of
reducing Municipal costs
we our greatest
impact will be to be look at single uh
packaging rather rather than such things
as mattresses tires and paints which are
all very important I think that's part
of a comprehensive bill
but if we really want to
lower the cost to Consumers so that's
our
May if it were and I'm not saying it
necessarily is even but if it were would
you say that um looking at packaging is
the strongest area to
it's it's a strong area I mean because
you're taking the cost of recycling not
disposal but of recycling away from
consumers
um that said I think that you know one
thing I'll say is that I think that
you'll have pushback from the hauling
community so the you know the private
haulers the waste managements the
republics not to call anybody out I know
this is going on a video somewhere
um but we're trying to figure out how to
how to work with those guys because we
we hear them and we hear that they have
very legitimate concerns
um about what happens to their
for-profit businesses and they're trying
to make money just like everybody else
and so we're trying to figure out how to
collaborate with them in better ways so
that we're not taking their autonomy
away from them but I just I'm putting
that as like a flag for you that I think
that you'll probably hear from them
and I thank you for these flags along
the way they are I'm sure they'll be
thank you I want to thank you so much
for your time today thank you for having
me and um Adam behind me you can always
get in touch with us we are so happy to
we have a scheduled
um P well um
Peter Blair will be speaking to us from
uh just zero
at 10 o'clock you set up to come in in
the meantime I'm wondering if you may
hear from
I know which one came in first Ann or
Christine uh
foreign
I'm Christine baber from Dover I am the
co-chair of the Dover plastic reduction
group and a member of the New Hampshire
Network plastic working group both
non-partisan citizen volunteer groups
I'm pleased that our state is actively
studying extended producer
responsibility in order to develop a
plan for product manufacturers to share
responsibility for reducing the
environmental impact of their products
for reducing the waste stream going into
our landfills and saving money for
I think that
um the the previous person who spoke
mentioned the the benefit some of the
benefits of Shifting financial
responsibility Upstream to manufacturers
this would also provide incentives for
them to reduce production of difficult
to dispose of materials and to
incorporate environmental considerations
into the designs of their products and
packaging
Six States have epr or similar bills
covering packaging California Colorado
Maine Oregon New Jersey and Washington I
hope we will add New Hampshire to the
list
an epr bill would have multiple benefits
for New Hampshire according to a report
by the recycling partnership that looked
at the impact of epr programs in seven
jurisdictions worldwide and in six U.S
states
implementing epr programs and these are
effective strong epr programs can
increase overall residential recycling
rates by as much as 48 percentage points
can create nearly universal access to
recycling can increase overall
participation in recycling can boost the
amount of recycled content by millions
of tons also can recapture between 13
million and 91 million in Lost material
in addition it can reduce hundreds of
thousands of metric tons of climate
damaging emissions in these states and
very importantly can create thousands of
jobs
we all in New Hampshire are concerned
about our taxpayers and costume
municipalities
epr will reduce costs for these groups
the product stewardship Institute claims
that under current recycling systems the
consumer actually pays three times
first for the packaging of the product
that they buy which is included in the
cost of the goods a second time for
collection recycling or disposing of
that package through Municipal Taxes or
private subscription costs and a third
time for the indirect costs associated
with post-consumer packaging such as
increased health insurance premiums
resulting from higher illness and
disability caused by pollution
some who benefit from our current system
of dealing with product waste allege
that epr legislation will raise costs
for consumers however the conservation
law Foundation asserts that there is no
credible data indicating epr would raise
consumer prices
in conjunction with the Natural
Resources Council of Maine they
estimated that adopting an epr policy
would save Maine's
Municipal taxpayers at least 16 million
a year
it could reasonably be expected that
similar savings could occur in New
Hampshire
because of the groups within which I'm
involved
we believe that single-use plastic
packaging needs to be included in
extended producer
innate extended producer bill
there is a long line of products that
would benefit from extended producer
responsibility but we strongly Advocate
that single-use plaque plastic be
involved
U.S plastic recycling rates which were
only about nine percent in 2015 are now
reported to have dropped to about five
percent
and we are learning more almost every
week about the health hazards as well as
environmental hazards associated with uh
84 of plastic waste goes to our
landfills and 11 is incinerated
releasing more toxics into the
environment
we we need to prohibit the use of
hazardous chemicals in Plastics and
significantly reduce the production of
single-use plastics while choosing safer
sustainable materials that could support
one of the really encouraging pieces of
research that I have found is that
voters support adopting policies such as
epr a 2023 Nationwide poll of U.S voters
found overwhelming support from both
Republicans 75 percent of the
Republicans pulled and Democrats 86
percent of the Democrats for Shifting
the cost of cleaning up plastic
pollution from taxpayers to the
companies that make and use plastic
90 percent of registered Democrats and
79 percent of registered Republicans
were concerned about the extent of
plastic found in our environment
76 percent of Republicans and 89 percent
of Democrats are concerned that less
than six percent of plastics are being
recycled and the rest sent to landfills
exported incinerated or discarded into
the environment
therefore it's not surprising that 82
percent of Democrats and 70 percent of
Republicans agree that companies should
stop producing and using so much
single-use plastic an epr would
undoubtedly do that
and in conclusion to that piece 66
percent of Democrats and 70 percent of
Republicans say that taxpayers shouldn't
have to pay for the cleanup of plastic
luckily we have a strong model epr bill
that exists to guide New Hampshire
legislators work
the model epr Bill developed by just
zero and Beyond plastic
addresses the key requirements for
Effective packaging reduction including
strong oversight and accountability
providing Financial relief to taxpayers
and consumers reducing toxics in
packaging and establishing environmental
standards for packaging among others
this bottle bill could be easily adapted
to New Hampshire and I think would
address the uh multiple types of
products that we would cover
um
this per the the earlier discussion a
strong effective extended producer
responsibility Bill offers the
opportunity to reduce waste going to our
burgeoning landfills
to protect the health of our environment
and our residents to increase jobs and
to reduce the economic costs of dealing
with difficult to recycle plastic in
other ways
I hope this committee will seize this
opportunity and work to pass an epr bill
in New Hampshire and both our Dover
group and the plastic working group
stand ready to assist in whatever way we
thank you
please
um I'm not sure I don't know a lot about
it but in Northumberland there's a pilot
program where they're taking
non-recyclable Plastics and turning it
into fuel do you have any information on
that
um I don't know about that particular
program
but they're
there there is again growing concern
about taking Plastics
incinerating them
um
releasing the toxics that they carry
into our environment and we know you
know just recently with
um Sango Bain situation
the trouble we get ourselves into in
releasing toxic substances into our
environment
so you know our approach is go Upstream
reduce the Plastics particularly
single-use Plastics there are Plastics
that you know are very important in
but a lot of the Plastics that is that
are being produced are non-essential
polluting
and thank you also for your testimony um
could we get a copy of your testimony
and may also asked the prior speaker I
can give you my email address if you
need it I have I have copies okay
um
if you don't mind mailing it I if if
it's
um I can do both yeah
makes it easier to put a record that way
so thank you
and uh and I have no questions but then
again I think I've
oh I do have one question
um
and this is something which I don't
expect to answer for right now you say
that our recycling rates dropped from
nine to five percent on many of these
could you Plastics yes could you find me
your citation on that absolutely it's
what it's just it's in there in here
perfect perfect thank you so much sir I
was surprised to hear that but not
we have
my eye eyes on this time maybe I can get
and plug nippy
am I close
it
and um
we have a
I don't want to limit your testimony we
have about 15 minutes before we have one
somebody else scheduled if that's if if
we have
free time to run over may I interrupt
and come back is that possible I just my
name is Ann pod lipney I am from Chester
I am also part of the New Hampshire
Network Plastics working group and
Christine baber did such an excellent
job of representing us that I don't have
very much to add at all just a couple of
little points but I think Christine
covered the the ground extremely well so
the only thing I wanted to add is that
according to what I've found in my
research the recycling rate for
container deposit programs is 75 percent
if you don't have such a program the
recycling rate is only 38 percent so
there's an enormous difference between
those two the those percentages
um the other factoid is I've also found
uh from the container recycling
Institute that the 10 bottle Bill States
recycle
490 containers per capita per year at a
cost of 1.53 cents per unit the 40
non-body non-bottle Bill States recycle
191 containers per capita per year at a
cost of 1.24 cents per unit thus for a
minimal price increase more than two and
a half times as many containers are
recovered
so you can see the importance of this
whole Initiative for uh epr and finally
no State bottle bill has ever been
repealed which is interesting and three
have expanded California Maine and
Oregon have expanded to con to uh can
include other containers so uh that's a
good fact to know that no bottle bill
has ever been repealed and in fact it's
the beginning of expanding them to other
categories
so that's all I have to add again I
think Christine has beautifully covered
the environmental hazards the risk to
human health and the importance of
reducing uh waste in our waste stream uh
especially to prevent landfill buildup
and build up of plastic waste in our
oceans rivers streams and other
so much for testimony and for updating
us on the battle bills which I don't
know if there'll be more to be said
about that in the future or not
and I also should add I don't know if
that's really part of this particular
uh legislation I really can't say
um but uh but thank you for picking it
up they're good that's very good
information
and again could we get a copy of your
just email if you don't mind I will
you're going to recess for about 10
minutes sir while we get ready for our
next uh person to testify
uh speaking for the committee
if anybody would care this is probably a
little unusual but if anybody would care
to come sit on this side of the table so
you may watch as well you are welcome to
do so
and good morning Peter I don't know if
yes we can thank you so much well it
uh
yes we I I think we're looking forward
to that in fact
awesome
are you able to see the PowerPoint
yes we are and I think we're all ready
to get started when whenever you would
a new environment the organization we
work with policy makers experts
communities uh to implement just
Equitable and sensible solutions to
waste management issues a key component
of my job
understanding the website of YMCA
policies and proposals that solve waste
management issues in an SM the last
year's specific event understanding
producer responsibility for faculty and
paper material or eprer
at least four years this has become
probably the most widely discussed zero
waste policy in the country so where are
we
similar to what you guys have done with
your study commission but they're
actually doing a comprehensive needs
assessment to to figure out the
landscape and design a program that's
tailored for their State uh look at just
the laws that have passed that doesn't
tell you the full picture so in 2023
there were 18 different epr for
packaging bills introduced across 12
States uh and the interest in this
policy really is not that surprising we
have a packaging waste crisis in this
country roughly a third of all household
waste is some form of packaging so think
plastic wrap cardboard boxes styrofoam
bubble wrap all of that
and right now uh we're buying things but
we don't really want the packaging but
we're stuck paying for the packaging
anyway because it just comes with the
products we're buying I think we've all
had the experience where you buy
something probably online only to end up
ultimately most of this is unrecyclable
plastic that can't be put anywhere
except into a landfill into a narrator
or littered to other countries three
options that are expensive and
environmentally problematic
um and without new laws this just is not
going to change uh right now the
companies that design uh their products
really have no incentive to change this
system uh because we're the ones stuck
paying to collect and manage all of this
materials uh in fact these companies
have an incentive to just make sure that
their packaging their products as
cheaply as possible since they're not
connected to the end of like management
of it but this really doesn't make sense
because local governments consumers we
don't have control over how these
products are being designed or the
materials they're using to package their
products so it's really this chicken and
egg game where they create a new type of
packaging some new type of plastic
and we're stopped trying to design items
that can manage is not working so epr
for packaging is designed to address it
by first and foremost taking that
Financial incentive to pay for the cost
of collecting managing transporting all
this packaging waste and disposing it
and recycling it from residents from
taxpayers from communities and put it
back on the companies that have control
over these products when properly
developed these programs can
significantly increase recycling rates
create a pathway towards a circular
economy and most importantly reduce
waste in general here's how these
programs work each company that sells or
distributes products using any type of
single-use packaging has to be a part of
a producer responsibility organization
has to be a part of the program
the program is going to be overseen by
the state but implemented by that Pro
that produce a responsibility
organization and each individual
producer is going to pay fees that cover
the whole cost of the system some of
that money is going to go towards
reimbursing local governments for the
cost of managing the waist and the rest
of it is going to go towards system
improvements making sure our recycling
system is working making sure that
everything is moving to the end goals
the end markets that we want it to
that's traditional epr we've seen a new
interest in also making sure that these
systems are well designed and that
there's pressure on producers to change
the way that they're designing and
marketing their products through
performance standards
now all of this sounds really simple
right but obviously it's very nuanced
when you're trying to actually Implement
one of these programs so what just
Sierra has done is two things first
we've created model legislation to help
States Implement programs for their
jurisdictions it's model legislation so
there's a lot of boilerplate language
that we think could be applied to all
programs but really it can be tailored
by legislators to meet your
state-specific needs but we've also
created a list of essential components
for a successful epr for packaging
program and both the model legislation
and our components were created by
looking at the existing programs across
the world the laws that have been passed
here in the US and the bills that are
being considered to really understand
how these programs how these are trying
to address the really thorny complex
issues when it comes to setting up a
very big overarching program like APR
for packaging so I'm just going to run
through with those essential components
are and also if you have any questions
at any point just stop me
I'd like to stop here for a moment if I
may
yes
um is there any way you can make your
PowerPoint full screen I think at least
I'm having trouble seeing some of it
um okay I was full screen for me uh bear
with me for a second I'm gonna stop
despite my youthful look I'm not as good
okay uh is it full screen now
I think that's it's much better
yeah it does I think that is full screen
at this point
sorry I had a little trouble hearing you
there oh yes short answer yes
okay great um sorry about that so okay
the essential components for strong epr
packaging program the first the holistic
make sure the program covers all
packaging material all papers possible
with minimal exemptions uh and you want
to make sure you're covering the whole
range of producers of this packaging
material with some exemptions for small
businesses uh data driven you want to
make sure that the program is reflecting
the needs of your specific States so you
do that with a comprehensive needs
assessment at the beginning second don't
put the industry in charge regulated
producers should have a role in the
development of the program it is
producer responsibility at all but that
rule really should not be in setting the
core values of the program things like
setting the fees determining the
performance standards those types of
things those are better left with the
state
next create a strong transparent Key
System the money created from the
program is a really big component of
this so you want to make sure that it is
covering the whole cost of the program
and that the fees are actually being
used to incentivize good behavior by the
companies next with all of that money
you also want to make sure it's going
towards the objectives of the law so
reimbursing towns and cities for their
Recycling and Disposal costs and funding
new infrastructure to make sure the
system's working even better next you
want to make sure you have clear
enforceable strong performance standards
the fees alone even with Eco modulation
which I'll get into in a little bit just
aren't going to give you widespread
benefits that can come from this type of
program you really want to set
environmental performance standards as
part of the program that produce the
meat
avoiding glaring loopholes uh this is a
new type of policy there's a lot of
nuance to it so there's a lot of ways
that you can insert or you can insert
language to undermine the effectiveness
of the program so you want to make sure
that that's not included and then
finally you can say that's about any
type of law but you really wrong
oversight account be an enforcement a
good law on paper really is nothing if
it's not going to be enforced it's
okay be holistic let's try to cover as
much packaging and paper as we can so
first and foremost what does that mean
it means covering primary secondary and
tertiary packaging most epr for
packaging programs only focus on primary
packaging and that's the packaging uh
that we get when we go and buy a product
but there's a lot of back-end packaging
that gets Associated from the
development of the product shipping it
to the Distributors and ultimately the
retailers so you want to make sure
that's covered
um there are some exemptions things that
shouldn't be covered under this program
reusable and refillable packaging that's
where we want the direction to go we
want to get away from single use from
that linear create use dispose system so
if you have reusable refillable
packaging that shouldn't be covered to
incentivize companies to switch to that
this containers paint other packaging
that are better covered by a more
targeted program those should be
excluded and covered by their own
producer Responsibility program and then
certain packing is covered by federal
law and regulation the food drug and
cosmetic act those things you'll run
into preemption issues sometimes so you
need to be careful about making sure
that you accept those if you don't run
into any legal issues there
so just quickly I mentioned this but
when it comes to figuring out what those
targeted specific types of packaging
that are better managed by other
programs uh the biggest one is a bottle
Bill uh there's been a renewed interest
in Bottle bills wow there's been this
uptick in epr for packaging interest and
it makes sense both of them are
packaging uh widely glittered products
things that are just not being recycled
as possible really the question
shouldn't be do you include bottle bills
and epr for packaging it should be how
to create a complementary bottle Bill
system and there's three reasons you
really want a separate bottle Bill
program the first when you include
beverage containers in epr for packaging
you're losing the litter reduction
benefits that are core to bottle bills
so when you have a bottle Bill program
and you place that refundable deposit on
every single used beverage container
sold in the state that creates an
incentive for people to hold on to their
empty cans and bottles bring them back
for recycling and make sure that they're
properly managed that's really important
because beverage containers are
generally consumed on the go right have
them in your car you have them when
you're leaving the house there's a
reason we see Coke bottles beer bottles
all these things littered across our
neighborhoods but you're not seeing uh
cereal boxes or peanut butter it's
because beverage containers are
different from us packaging they're
consumed on the go so if you want that
litter reduction you need a bottle build
second recycling beverage containers are
made of materials that are highly
recyclable if they're actually kept
clean and uncontaminated so when you
create a bottle build program you're
creating a standalone system that is
just managing those containers your
guaranteeing that you have a clean
stream of high quality recycled content
that can be repurposed into new things
if you have them in an epr packaging
system they're going to stay in that
single stream they're going to stay in
the you know curbside recycling system
and you're just not going to get the
same benefits and then third and perhaps
most importantly is you lose the ReUse
and refill value if you don't have
so bottle meals create the consumer
culture as well as the systems needed to
transition from single-use beverage
containers to reusable and refillable
ones uh Oregon has already done this
they've had their bottle Bill program
for I think they're the the second
longest so it's been since about the 70s
and recently they've started to
integrate reusable beverage containers
into their programs and for the consumer
nothing's changed they still go and drop
off the containers at their Redemption
Center points of drop off but instead of
having the bottles crushed up and
recycled they're clean sterilized and
reused which has significant
so okay that's what's regulated now the
big question is who's regulated uh who
is the producer under the system uh
generally it's anyone who sells offers
for sale or distributes products using
single use packaging in the state but
what's really important is that you use
a tiered approach to Define insert with
the goal of targeting the largest
possible company who could be considered
the producer of the product of the
packaging itself
that way you're not going after just a
small in-state business that is selling
it on behalf of a bigger company right
the idea is to get changes in the design
of the packaging so you want to make
sure you're regulating the company that
has control over how the product is
being designed
and you should have some exemptions for
small businesses generally when you look
at the laws that have passed these
exemptions are kind of twofold the first
is you pick a certain amount of gross
annual income and if a company makes
under that they're accepted from the
program and the second is if they're
using a relatively small amount of
packaging material to sell and
distribute their products this typically
okay so that's the first one next is a
data-driven program using a
comprehensive needs assessment to figure
out what the specifics of your state are
so you can have a really tailored
program
um so when it comes to waste management
and especially packaging waste we really
have a limited amount of data we don't
know how much packaging ways the state
is dealing with how much of it's cycled
how much of it's deposed of what types
of materials are actually recyclable in
your jurisdiction all of this
information is really necessary to
having a strong program so what you want
to do with the outset is require this
needs assessment to figure out where
things stand now how do we get them to a
better place and what are the
opportunities for targeted Investments
and how much does it actually cost to
manage all this material in the first
place and you can do this either as part
of a comprehensive bill or you can pass
a standalone needs assessment bill which
is what Maryland and Illinois did this
year
so next uh this is a very big component
of it is figuring out the right balance
between the state and the producer
responsibility organization the the pro
the non-profit entity that's going to
kind of run the system on behalf of the
producers
so responsibility does not mean
unregulated producer control over the
program in reality it means the opposite
the laws and regulations that are
designed the program are going to be I
said they're going to say clear
understandable and enforceable standards
which The Producers must meet and then
the producer responsibility organization
we recommend there's only one so all the
producers are under this umbrella uh are
going to be responsible for complying
with the components of the law
to ensure the breakdown of his power
there's two things you can do and
actually Maine's program did both abuse
really well in my opinion the first is
have in the law a clear breakdown of
what the responsibilities for the pro is
and what the state is and the second is
to not let the producers themselves just
create the producer responsibility
organization but have the state select
one through a comprehensive bidding
process so first figuring out who should
be in charge of what the state should be
in charge of the really big picture
things things like setting the
performance standards setting the fees
determining the fee structures and
ultimately determining what type of
packaging is readily recyclable in your
jurisdiction on the other hand the
producer responsibility organization
should act more as a data and compliance
applicator they should be responsible
for collecting the fees from
participating producers making sure that
all the compliance data is being sent in
an understandable format to the
department and making sure that the
producers are meeting the requirements
under the law again to help with this
that competitive solicitation process
that Maine's doing should really help
they're going to issue an RFP and then
people are going to bid to be that
okay this are obviously a very big
they'll produce responsibility uh you
want to make sure that the fees are
designed in a clear and transparent way
so one of the most important thing is to
make sure that you're covering the whole
cost associated with the program so what
does that include the actual cost of
collecting transporting managing dealing
with all the covered packaging material
that should be included in the fees next
you want to make sure that the
Department's environmental
administrative enforcement all of their
work to keep this program afloat is
being covered so that you don't need
taxpayer funding to keep this thing
going the pros administration of the
program kind of that breakdown I just
talked about they are going to have a
role that should be covered by the
program as well and then also things
like the cost of promulgating the rules
paying for the needs assessment you want
all of that big into the overarching fee
so this is really a completely closed
loop that the fees the producers are
paying over the entire system you don't
need outside funding you're not going to
run into play issues
foreign
so that's the large fees in general how
you figure out the big pot what the
whole system is going to cost Nick
making sure that the individ producer
payments are designed in a way to seek
environmental benefits so each
individual producer is going to pay a
quart of that big number but fee based
on the amount of packaging material that
they use any type of packaging material
that they use and each type of material
is probably going to have a different
fee so things like paper and cardboard
that are highly recyclable that have
good recycling rates those are going to
probably have a lower fee in something
like
single-use plastic film which really can
only be burned or buried
um so that's how you're going to get a
base fee but then that base fee should
be further change and eco-modulated and
this is just adjusting it to incentivize
good behavior so if the specific type of
packaging you're talking about is
recyclable if it doesn't have toxic
materials in it if it has a certain
portion of recycled content all things
will want to see that producer species
Rock and conversely those who aren't
doing those things are using
unrecyclable materials who have
Incorporated recycled content who
haven't faced out toxic materials their
fees will increase
any kind of marketing for the results we
want to see packaging reduction in
redesign
next make sure that the money is
actually funding the solutions so
there's going to be different ways the
money is used to the program the first
kind of bucket is covering the cost of
the program I talked about this already
make sure that a good chunk of the money
is just keeping the system running and
taking care of the whole system's cost
of administration but the second is more
about funding improvements to recycling
and packaging management you want to
make sure that there's Investments that
are going to help reduce packaging waste
and improve Recycling and you do this in
two ways first is by those reimbursement
payments to cover local government's
cost of managing packaging ways this
will significantly reduce their tax
burdens it will shift that Financial
component of the understanding of manage
packaging waste from good use that to
the producers and next is you don't just
want to fund the system that we have
currently because it's unfortunately not
working so you want to make sure that
there's funds for system improvements
and you do that to targeted grants that
are going to improve the waste
management system
so we recommend doing that through a
packaging reduction and recycling grant
program so a portion of the money will
go into this fund the producer
responsibility organization is going to
be responsible for reviewing Grant
applications and making recommendations
to the State Environmental agency here
the Department of Environmental Services
about what should be funded the grants
need to be focused on eliminating
single-use packaging increasing the
transition of singlings packaging to
reusable and refillable packaging
increasing the recyclability of
single-use packaging uh investments in
reuse and rebuild infrastructure which
are going to be necessary and providing
education and Outreach so everyone knows
the proper ways management methods for
oh so a lot of that is just fee based
right what I've talked about at this
point but unfortunately that's not
really going to do a good enough job to
get the kind of widespread changes that
we want
um
you know just creating a system that
shifts of paying and paying uh packaging
waste from individuals local governments
to the producers just is not going to
work uh in fact as a result of kind of
exclusively focusing on this speed
shifting uh mechanisms existing producer
responsibility laws really haven't
achieved the significant packaging waste
production or packaging redesign that we
want to see and that's because a lot of
the money is continuing to flow
Downstream towards collection disposal
and recycling so even when the programs
attempt to kind of get around this
through Eco modulation what I talked
about before incentivizing good behavior
punishing bad it's really just not a
strong enough economic trigger to have
serious change so what you want to do
with effective modern producer
responsibility programs is set clear
environmental standards that focus on
packaging cycling we're talking about
rates and dates setting specific targets
for when a certain amount of packaging
has to be reduced and how much that
needs to be recycled
um this is starting to happen especially
in the U.S California currently is
packaging reduction requirements in
their law and they only applied a
plastic plastic packaging but it's a
good start Oregon's program has a very
specific recycling requirements for both
plastic packaging and single-use Food
Service wear they're requiring that all
of that material will be recycled at a
rate of 25 by 2028 50 by 2040 and then
70 by 2015. uh Maine's law did not
actually set any of these performance
standards in statute but they're being
figured out through the rulemaking
process which is happening right now
um next avoid flaring loopholes again
this is a new type of program it's
Innovative which that invites a whole
bunch of nonsense and uh ways that users
can minimize stiffness of the program
and this is really important because
these programs take a while to get off
the ground for instance Maine passed
their launch live 2021 they're still in
the process of developing the Draft
rules we're talking probably two to
three more years before their programs
fully implemented so if you have any
loopholes or inefficiencies in your
program in the law it's going to take a
while before the program is even up and
running pretty last end so the two
biggest ones we're seeing is inviting
false Solutions so weak definitions of
recycling that allow for things like
Advanced recycling or chemical recycling
this could be its own topic
so I'm not going to go into all of it I
will just say there is a significant
amount of data that shows that advanced
recycling or chemical recycling does not
actually result in the meaningful
recycling of plastic material
um and another common thing we're seeing
is just very large and vague exemptions
California's law has a really good
example of this they're going to exempt
any single-use packaging material that
presents a unique challenge in terms of
compliance with the law as an attorney
that's just a gold mine no one knows
what that's going to mean you can
litigate that for years to come and it's
going to result in a lot of material
being excluded which doesn't need not
there it just means being paid for by
the system
and then finally strong oversight
accountability and enforcement you can
say this with any type of law but you
really want to make sure what you write
on paper is going to have a real world
impact so enforcement make sure the
State Environmental agency has adequate
enforcement measures in the law to bring
actions against individual producers and
the pro oversight you want periodic
audits of the program to track how much
money is being brought in is that money
being spent in accordance with the
requirements of the law and our
producers complying with the
environmental standards that are set and
then finally accountability you want to
make sure that all of this is publicly
transparent that people can weigh in on
the system and that they understand it I
know that was a lot probably very
quickly so I'm happy to answer any
questions
um
one of the keys that seems to have an
effective program is making sure that um
we have
adequate what I would assume would be
consumer sorting of these various
products uh keeping uh bio waste you
know compostable things out of the waste
flow
um
making sure that
things are separated properly and this
would probably require some amount of
Education to the consumer
uh you were you had quite a list of what
uh could be done Beyond
uh just the fees themselves being levied
back
um is consumer education is part of that
did I miss that
so where education is a big part of it
necessarily the state
um they're the ones who are
manufacturing the products they're going
to have this kind of umbrella of the
producers that understand their products
and the packaging associated with it we
see a big role that they're going to
play is creating that uniformed list of
educational materials that paint what is
recyclable what can actually be recycled
in let's say New Hampshire what
currently isn't how they should be
managed those types of things and
education is a big part of these
programs especially in Europe where
they've been in place since the 1990s
we will get a copy of that PowerPoint is
that correct
yes I can send you a copy the PowerPoint
and I didn't necessarily have a written
testimony but bullet points which I'm
also happened to Fair sure that that
both would be very helpful
um
I think I'll save the rest of my
questions for all flying if that's okay
I need to do a little processing on this
but I want to thank you for your
testimony
thank you so much for having me
could I ask a question
foreign
yes go ahead please uh yes I have a
question
um I know in the process of
making plastic
thousands of chemicals are being used
none of them or very few of them are
ever regulated or restricted
when you down cycle plastic
what incentive is there in this process
of repackaging and uh you know these epr
laws to reduce the number of chemicals
in plastic when it's being recycled
because when it gets recycled it's
coming back to us even though it's
downgraded we're still getting them and
what is the incentive for these
industries to reduce the number of
chemicals being used and and exposing
that's a great question
um currently right now no incentive
right they're completely detached from
the end of life management of this if
they include toxics and they're fill and
if those toxic does when we're using the
products when they're being recycled
it's not their problem through epr
there's kind of two ways you can do it
the first is that Eco modulation so
making sure that the fees are tailored
to those environmental outcomes and most
of the programs that are coming up in
the U.S they have Eco modulation for
toxic so if you reduce the amount of
toxics that are present in your
packaging your feed goes down if you
still have harmful toxins in the
packaging fee goes up so that's that's
one way and that can be very helpful the
other way is with those performance
standards I was talking about calling
out specific types of toxics and just
phasing them out and requiring that all
of The Producers regulated under this
program must phase out X toxins in our
bill we've done that I is a list of the
common problematic toxics in plastic and
consumer good packaging as a starting
point and then allowing the state
environment agency to periodically
remove additional toxic materials and
determine if they should be included in
the program and included in that phase
out so it is a big problem and you can't
really have anything that's recyclable
if it has toxics in it because even if
they're present in the initial packaging
when you create it heating them up going
through the recycling process it really
does increase the likelihood that
one more question from our
representative
Sherry dutzy
hi Peter uh representative Sherry dutzy
here how you doing uh I had a question
about the echo modulation and how is
that regulated would we as a state have
to set up uh maybe a a laboratory that
you know if the packaging has been
changed then the producer just submits
the new packaging for testing so that we
know that the formula has been changed
ultimately you'd want the state to come
up with the entire fee structure and
Maine is going through this process
right now with their rules so you're
going to figure out a laundry list of
packaging in general you're going to
assign a fee to each type of packaging
so Plastics one two three four all the
way through seven cardboard paper glass
steel aluminum
and then you're gonna figure out in the
legislation or in the rulemaking process
how you want to Eco modulate it what is
going to be given kind of pluses and
minuses and then the producers are going
to pay individual fees based on their
packaging portfolio and they're going to
have to submit uh you know plans not
plan sorry um
reports to the pro to show kind of where
they are okay with this specific type of
car packaging it's got a 50
post-consumer to recycled content uh
that's why our fees should be this and
the pro is responsible for collecting
the fees and doing everything with the
money but the state sets the
requirements and then those audits I
talked about in the enforcement section
that's how you make sure everything's
you know working as properly as it
should be and that there's no funny
those are one of those things that sound
a lot more complicated than you think
but I'd encourage you to look at Maine's
process where they're figuring out the
rules and it is complicated but you know
we've got a lot of very complicated
environmental programs in this country
foreign thank you again Peter and I
don't think we have many more questions
for you and I want to thank you for the
excellent questions in addition to
um what you presented
and I'm seeking for our next meeting I
would really like to consult with our
two absent members before we reschedule
does that make sense to you
um beyond that I believe our business
I'm not going to ask for a motion to
adjourn